this anniversary
30th year of pain and suffering from me
and my family
well one of the most important thing
people must must not realize by now is
that it stored my family apart
My Two children and my grandchildren is
now living in in England we call it born
here
I had to then make decision up the fact
that I've lost all of my family whether
I stay here or or go back to where I
came from the fact that we actually
decided that we were going to bury
Stephen in Jamaica because of vandalism
was one of the main thing that caused me
to leave this country and I feel more at
home when I'm in Jamaica and also the
fact that it's very there I can go and
see him and look after his his grave so
that's one of the I I think people
didn't even realize that
Stephen had said at once says that when
he fully qualified as a as an architect
he was going to go and live in Jamaica
as well
so although he didn't manage to do it
himself we managed to take him back he
had a very bright future ahead of him as
well can you tell us a little bit more
about that and as a family what you're
looking forward to at that time when
Stephen decide what he wanted to become
he decided he wanted to be an architect
my dreams was to be an architect and I
then said to myself
well I'm sure Stephen's going to be able
to produce the goods to be an architect
and looking forward to seeing some of
his the building that maybe you decide
design and build all over the country
unfortunately for me and my family that
didn't happen
the the memories of my son growing up
remember you know this is my first child
the memories that I have of Stephen will
never go away you know when when Steve
was born in those days there you expect
cut Nets a lot of cut debts
when Stephen came out of hospital and
came home the first night when he was in
that cut I don't think I slept that
night I was getting up every minute to
make sure and listen to make sure that
he was breathing
[Music]
never
what do you think was so different about
your family's approach and about the
rest of Britain as well finally looking
in the mirror what what made it
different I think
um the the fact that I'm a department
person and I used to say to them I'm not
taking no for an answer I'm going to
find ways
to do what I need to do and to get
Justice from my son
um if that was a black person who had
gone out there and murdered somebody
within weeks you would have found out
who they are and so my son is not going
to go the killing of my son is not going
to go like the way you think it's going
to go it's going to go the way like I'm
gonna fight
tooth and nail to get some kind of
Justice not just
if the Justice I have to keep saying to
people that I've got so far is some
justice and when I say some justice that
mean I want the whole Justice
and what does the whole Justice look
like the old justices to get all the
other people that were involved in my
son murder
to go and spend time in prison for what
they have done because if that was my
son who had gone out there and killed
somebody
nobody will be talking about some
justice we're talking about Justice
how do you feel that
the idea of the police being
institutionally racist still exists 30
years on I'm disappointed you know I've
said this more than once
when the ring car was being kept
more today in Cary was done in in London
first and then we started going over to
Birmingham Manchester all these other
different cities and to take the inquiry
into those different communities of
people of those Community understand
some of the things that's happening in
London
I am so disappointed that oh many 19
years ago
or so
they were given a plan to try and make
the force better and they completely
ignore it that somebody else had to take
it on and come back with the same things
that we said 19 years ago
and I'm just saying it was a waste of
time and money for you to give somebody
something to make them better and they
ignored it so that we are still facing
the same kind of situation
2 000 years
2020-23 we still facing the same kind of
attitude of these people who suppose
we're protecting the Republic and I've
made it plain to people if something
happened to me tomorrow morning or even
now who do I call
and if I had to deal with the police I
wouldn't be calling them entrepreneur
police because I know I wouldn't get the
satisfaction of them treating me the way
it is supposed to
when I look and see that officers who
are supposed to be
looking after family going into a park
taking photographs of two dead people
and sending it as a joke all over the
place I can't believe these people
human beings there's been lots of
conversations about
um wanting your son's Killers to
eventually confess why is it important
that they do confess
for me if you 've done something as
Dreadful as
a murder and and some people there may
be still some people thinking that they
maybe didn't get the right people
for me if that person been convicted and
sent to prison
and is now wanting to come back and join
the society
they should be able to say whether or
not they're the person who actually did
the crime before they let out and into
the community
I don't have a doubt that they actually
did it but I want them to confess to the
world because a lot there may be lots of
people who still think that they weren't
the people and when it comes then to
those parole hearings do you think that
a confession should be
a part of that I don't know whether or
not I'm going to be allowed to go today
because the the parole here in our
at one says they were saying that maybe
I'll have to write some kind of
something towards it I don't know that I
haven't
spoken to my solicitor about that but
for me I think
if I don't have to write something then
I should be able to be present to to
hear some of the questions that they're
going to be asked
and if I'm if I'm able to say it to
whosoever is going to ask the question
ask them what they're going to ask and
if it's possible for me to put a
question in then I'll do that
and what would you like to say or to ask
them
Stephen is
buried in Jamaica he's dead he's never
going to be able to come out to that
coffin and where he's in
these people have served 14 years or
whatsoever it is
out of my son was 18 years old he'd be
40 something now
I think it would be really
courteous courteous for them for me to
ask whosoever
is been sent to prison did you actually
kill my son I want you to say yes I
killed Stephen Lawrence to make me feel
satisfied that way at least got some
people because we know there's still
three four or something still walking
around we'll never be
persecuted because they
they met at the good idea of closing the
case that in case somebody who maybe
know more about the case after so many
years decide that you know I've kept the
secrets for so long now I need to put it
out for them to solve their skills and
find the rest of the people who actually
kill my son
it's frustrating because when you look
at um
the destruction that they've caused
especially for me and for me to lose my
family that I have to move away from
here
away from the rest of my family and go
and live somewhere else because I can't
stand the idea of being here
it's devastating
I won't I would never forgive the police
as long as as they can't accept
what they're doing is wrong
because if you don't accept it it's not
going to change
you're going to be the same on 20 odd
years later for somebody else to come
along and say the same thing
that shows you that they have no
intention of changing their behavior
you know in the in the in the early days
when I came to this country in 1960s
if I was out on the street
looking for somewhere to go like a
addressing on a road or something and I
saw officer or I saw a police station
I'd go on ox
in those days you'll get an answer and
you'll get a Direction
no I wouldn't ask them for nothing I
wasn't even born when your son was
killed however I grew up my entire life
knowing who your son was and
understanding the change that had been
created as a result of his death I'm
interested to see what you think about
that and whether or not you believe that
there is a difference between your
generation's experience the police and
Britain as a whole compared to what mine
might have been well I'm you know in a
way what you just said
something made me feel good to know that
I'm able to talk to the younger
generation and tell them certain things
about the way their peers
give two hours Us in the early days and
for them to understand that it was wrong
and for for them to do things different
from the way it's some of their parents
were doing it I'm I'm feel grateful for
that the only thing that I'm
not too happy about is that it had to
take the death of my son
for anything like that to happen